jean meyer la nuit des rois c'est une
pièce que vous connaissez bien mais
c'est la première fois que vous la
montée en plein air est ce que l vous
imposer des difficultés oh oui et non
c'est à dire que le cadre de fourvière
je crois se prête admirablement à une
pièce qui est une série qui est un
compte à la fois politique et comique et
je crois que ce cadre surtout aménagé
par mon ami georges wakhévitch qui a
fait vraiment un miracle je croise c'est
un cadre enchanteur site c'est une pièce
qui touche la mythologie à la mythologie
de lamoura de mythologie du rire et qui
se trouve par conséquent très à sa place
dans un lieu est idéal comme celui de
fourvière
tous se battent qui sourient et moi qui
faisais appeler pour quelque chose de
grave quelque chose de grave à table je
ne demande qu'à ne pas sourire
si certains croient zygel quelque peu
bas circulation mais quelle importance
si la vue est agréable de certaines
dates
il osera pour moi comme dans la sous ce
seuil on ne fait pas loi dans mon esprit
madame quoique vu son but par forget ou
le secret tombée entre nos mains
tous les commandements seront exécutés
du coup les onze à seize docteur
écriture hommes
holly oh oui ma chérie pas mais toi oh
mon dieu
quelque chose pour lui qu'est ce que tu
as malvolio à sourire ainsi à tous baisé
la main sans arrêt pourquoi vous rendez
vous répondre et je trouvais les
rossignols répond le piano pour moi
c'est vous êtes ridicules aux animateurs
de la noblesse ne défraie pas c'était
écrit doigt sur plus long est content tu
parles à malvolio certains sont nobles
de naissance 20 20
certains contiennent que des cours d'eau
est pauvre il y ait des guérisons jean
leplat vous retrouvez le festival de
lyon vous avez déjà travaillé il ya
quelques années quels souvenirs
avez-vous gardé d'excellents souvenirs
j'avais monté le cyrano de bergerac avec
jacques du mesnil se croit qu'il ya
moins vite neuf ans comme ça et c'était
très amusant parce qu'ils avaient tout
l'espace scénique et par une très belle
et ce mal bolio de la nuit des rois que
vous avez interprété en salle à paris en
quoi est-il modifié par le plein air je
crois que c'est simplement une question
d'ampleur une question de force et
d'intensité interview au point de vue
interprétation pure n'est pas une
question de rythme qui doit être
toujours également soutenu mais pas trop
vite parce qu'il faut laisser le temps à
la voix de monter jusqu'au jusqu'au haut
des gradins
c'est agréable de d'interpréter
shakespeare ah oui le shakespeare en
plein air surtout parce que la nuit des
rois comme son nom l'indiqué est une
pièce fait pour le plein air